[Musique]
le président de la république va arriver
place de la bastille devant le bataillon
de nerveux la garde républicaine dans un
instinct
[Musique]
le président va descendre de voiture les
troupes présentes naturellement les
armes c'est la sonnerie au chant
[Musique]
le président va se porter devant le
drapeau l'hymne
[Musique]
pour moi
la batterie musique joue la marche
consulaire à marengo le président de la
république est suivie du premier
ministre du ministre des armées du
général d'armée aérienne mans un chef
d'état major des armées et du général de
corps d'armée clavé gouverneur militaire
de paris
il se dirige vers la tribune on vient
d'exécuter la marseillaise je vous
rappelle qu'elle est née à strasbourg
devant l'enthousiasmé révolutionnaire
est là ça les jambes au jet de l'île
violoniste amateur leur est improvisé
chez le maire de la ville
avec un tel succès que la meunerie damba
qualité aussi tout ce qui était encore
qu'un chant de guerre pour l'armée du
rhin dans l'intérêt de nos l'officier le
président et pose un bouquet de roses
il m'a semblé qu'il y en avait six
douzaines de vendre la colonne de
juillet
[Musique]
le chant du départ le chant du départ de
melen des chants révolutionnaires les
plus évocateurs de cette époque et qui a
été vous en souvenez le thème de la
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
de monsieur giscard d'estaing cmh en
plein mois révolutionnaire que napoléon
l'interview en 1804 quant à l'accord
l'homme de juillet bien ma foi elle a
été élevée à la mémoire de ceux qui
tombèrent au cours des journées
révolutionnaires de 1830 le président
serre la main
au nonce apostolique puis commission des
finances du sénégal au vice président du
conseil des ministres islandais au
prince héritier du temps gains et à
monsieur lopez président élu de colombie
puis il est mené là semble devant le
membre du gouvernement il est mené par
monsieur anglaise
devant les autres personnalités
j'y ai vécu j'ai serré la main de
monsieur des records du président pères
et maintenant des deux marichal le
maréchal leclerc de hauteclocque et le
maréchal de lattre de tassigny
aux premiers rangs du gouvernement un
peu à la droite de notre écran venant
donc d'en sortir
on la revoit madame simone weil ministre
de la santé
et vous
derrière le voisin la république
monsieur fourcade monsieur hamelin
monsieur bonnet
ministre des finances ministre et de son
ministre et cultures et tous les membres
du gouvernement
[Musique]
touchant au faubourg saint-antoine la
place semble voué aux émeutes en juillet
1830 les barricades s'ils dressent en
1840 à la one et du qui élèvent en
mémoire des victimes des journées de
juillet cette colonne de bronze surmonté
du génie de la liberté où saint gravé
leur nom d'andy que leurs corps sont
ensevelis dans le soubassement et les
corps des victimes de février 1848 qui
seront également transporter un peu plus
tard on me signale pendant quelques
secondes le premier passage d'avions la
patrouille acrobatique de france
[Musique]
le président ici est pris par les
caméras gérard herzog de manière être
entre le président de l'assemblée
nationale à gauche est présent laisser
la droite et derrière ou presque juste
derrière le super vieux poniatowski
ministre les temps derrière l'épaule
droite du président de la république
monsieur lecanu et garde des sceaux
derrière le cas des jeux tommasini et
derrière l'épaule gauche du président de
la république
ce premier ministre
nous allons donc voir les neuf gars
magistère du maurane 230e fouga magister
la paf la patrouille acrobatique de
france s'est dit et est équipé
successivement de vampires rêve 84 g
d'ouragan de mystère 4 1
elle évolue dans tout le ciel d'europe
et d'afrique en tant qu ambassadeur de
france auprès des pays visités et
représentant officiel de l'armée de mer
[Musique]
les biréacteurs d'entraînement avez-vous
d'un magistère que nous devrions voir
maintenant dans quelques secondes
non je pense que leur est respecté à 10
secondes près eh bien ils atteignent la
vitesse de 780 km l'air et leur
maniabilité est particulièrement
remarquable comme ils ont quelques
minutes de retard
une minute jusqu'à présent le président
de la république en profite pour serrer
les mains d'un certain nombre d'autres
personnes et des gouvernements balles
lorsque les le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
[Musique]
le ministre des affaires étrangères est
juste derrière
monsieur chirac voici les fougueux
magistère
[Musique]
race en leur signant bleu blanc rouge
dans le ciel et cela fait maintenant et
une fumée qui est poussé vers l'est par
le vent venu d'ouest
elle est poussée vers l'est et ce n'est
plus du bleu blanc rouge c'est
maintenant une teinte grise tandis que
derrière si vous ne voulez ce bleu blanc
rouge qui vient de passer le génie de la
liberté domine la place de la bastille
la situation et les idées une deuxième
vague est prévue à 9h40
ce sera une formation double chevron de
mirage cap bombardiers supersoniques
aile delta équipe et biréacteurs et le
défilé maintenant commence la garde
républicaine de paris
descendante du gué royal remontant donc
au xvème siècle organisé par saint louis
elle fut garde parisienne sous la
restauration garde républicaine
parisienne en 48 puis garde de paris
sword le deuxième empire garde
républicaine avec la troisième
république et c'est à la libération quel
prénom de garde républicaine de paris
davant par est composé de quarante
trompette et nous avons derrière trois
escadrons de la garde trois escadrons à
72 sap avec un étendard qui portent les
noms entre autres de la vingtaine
d'annes cycle de 1807 de frier de l'inde
et indochine 45 54
[Musique]
il remonte maintenant par le boulevard
beaumarchais le boulevard des filles du
calvaire et le boulevard du temple vers
la place de la république
sur fond de santé
ep
aussitôt derrière l'école polytechnique
l'école qui prépare une élite
scientifique a assumé son rôle de cadre
dans tous les domaines de l'activité
nationale
elle fut fondée en 1794 son drapeau fut
remis par l'empereur napoléon à aragon
le 3 décembre 1804 900 anciens élèves
tous officiers sont tombés au cours des
deux guerres au service de la france
les maréchaux niait les bosquets proches
jacques fayolle monnerie les savants
challes poincaré arago gay lussac les
philosophe auguste contre n'oubliez son
ancien élève de nix et monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing et ancien élève de
l'école polytechnique lui aussi le
président se tiendra debout pendant tout
le défilé il m'a dit je tiens à rester
debout les tout marche à pied c'est un
hommage que l'enfant en restant debout
dans ma tribune au lieu de m'asseoir
[Musique]
le boulevard beaumarchais et si l'on
prenait un peu à gauche c'est à dire la
droite de l'écran on se retrouverait
devant respirable place des bouges
[Musique]
on
le drapeau s'est incliné pour saluer le
chef de l'état et rier knicks les écoles
de great quittant l'école spéciale
militaire de saint-cyr label x donc que
nous voyons encore passer un instant
école militaire de saint cyr qui lui
font des bars long calendrier
révolutionnaire le 11 le real en dise
par bonaparte premier consul dans cette
vénérable maison seront formés jusqu'en
1940 gare admis l'officier qui venait
rang au pays la plupart de ses chèvres
[Musique]
le 1er bataillon de saint cyr le bâillon
des anciens à reçu le nom de promotion
de linares en souvenir du général ancien
des combats ses vacances en italie
la campagne de français d'indochine et
le 2ème bataillon sera baptisé aux
cérémonies du triangle de coëtquidan le
21 juillet dimanche prochain du nom du
maréchal de turenne dont on fête le
tricentenaire et dont la rue prend
exactement derrière ces maisons devant
lesquels passent maintenant
les jeunes chantent les coques des amis
d'airbus à sion ce n'est pas la seule
école de coëtquidan
il ya aussi l'école militaire interarmes
qui est née officiellement en 1961 et
qui recrute ses élèves officiers parle à
voix basse concours ouvert aux
sous-officiers officiers de réserve aux
activités de services
[Musique]
vous
les voici est en tenue bleue kebbi bleus
c est vous choisi le nom de procès du
nom du général ancien commandant de la
première division française libre elle
voisine a great qui dans nikko misérable
avec son aîné l'école spéciale militaire
de saint-cyr
[Musique]
la promotion procès de l'école militaire
interarmes rassemblement le chef de
l'état
[Musique]
on
enfin un spa l'école navale après ceux
de coëtquidan
une dame
[Musique]
c'est madame simone weil ministre de la
santé passée l'école navale co fondée en
1830 oui philippe après avoir été
jusqu'en 1914 installé sur un bâtiment
en rade de brest
les d'actuellement à lanvéoc poulmic et
c'est dans ce site que monsieur mais ce
père alors ministre des armées posa la
première pierre de la nouvelle école de
160 m de 27 sur la mer l'école navale
vise à donner à ses élèves un ensemble
de connaissances de base maritime m en
aval technique
les récents progrès de la science
l'horaire est respectée c'est l émir
achetable
[Musique]
en formation double chevron ces
bombardiers supersoniques à aile delta
équipés de pyrène terre en service
depuis 1964
[Musique]
toujours l'école navale je disais que
les récents progrès de la science la
transformation constante et rapide des
armes et des moyens fait que l'officier
de marine de posséder les qualités de
marin la ministre albert d'ingénieurs et
le diplomate toujours bonjour l'école
navale me signale un officier de marine
qui s'est approché de l'écran car il ne
peut plus traverser la place et vous
voyez des jeunes femmes les jeunes
femmes nous y viendrons tout à l'heure
vous faire une carrière dans la marine
après l'école militaire de la flotte
l'école de l'air qui est destiné à
former les futurs cadres supérieurs puis
l'école de saint pé de lyon et l'école
du service de santé de bordeaux
[Musique]
les élèves officiers de réserve d'un
ventre
[Musique]
les élèves officiers de réserve
d'enfants pris forme et à couettes qui
dans à côté dé saint cyrienne les élèves
officiers de l'école militaire
interarmes qui sont sélectionnés à
partir de la préparation militaire
supérieure ou dans des corps de troupe
où ils accomplissent leurs obligations
légales de service il sort du code titan
aspirants avant de prendre le
commandement dans la régie par la loi
prime autorisés ou de défense
opérationnelle du territoire
[Musique]
l'école nationale des sous-officiers
d'activé de saint-maixent fondeur 63 et
dans l'enseignement comprend trois
volets culture générale qui prépare les
lèvres rôle militaire et sociale du
futur sous-officier instruction
militaire qui disent les textes
officiels développe le coût du risque le
commandement et apporte de solides
connaissances tactiques et techniques et
enfin un entraînement physique la
pratique intensive du sport collectif et
de la natation
[Musique]
les marches sont joués sur un rythme
agréable mais un peu plus lentement que
les années passées la perspective du
boulevard beaumarchais qui va ensuite
fait preuve remplacer spears aux agapes
par le boulevard des filles du calvaire
et le boulevard du temple l'école
d'enseignement technique de l'armée de
terre étape d'issoire et de tulle c'est
d'école qui s'inscrit dans le plan de
modernisation de l'armée forme en trois
ans les sous-officiers des caissiers
indispensable à l'armée de terre ces
jeunes sont officielles substance 8 des
tâches techniques de leur spécialité
dans les corps de troupe et les
meilleurs d'entre eux peuvent devenir
officier
[Musique]
l'école des sous-officiers du service de
santé de chantoux la foule on rit non
loin d'orléans mission est bien
formation des sous-officiers de l'armée
de terre en santé dans les diverses
spécialités paramédical d'un secrétariat
et d'administration hospitalière ainsi
que des techniques des matériels
sanitaires
elle est chargée du maintien en
condition et du stockage des matériels
de l'élément médical militaire
l'intervention rapide et comme dans
l'armée on aime parler par initiale a
semblé éléments médical militaire
bavarois se rappelle m me line avec 2 1
le centre d'instruction des spécialistes
de l'aviation légère de l'armée perd 2,6
à l'apd azn ans ou qui est chargée
notamment de l'instruction de base des
agneaux du pilote et d appeler de toute
déformation de la lacc
c'est à dire l'aviation légère de
l'armée de terre il forme également
sous-officier spécialistes peuvent donc
des confrères
[Musique]
il
c'est pas la première fois que l'on est
et le place de la bastille bien au
contraire
célébrée sur les champs elysées jusqu'à
l'armistice de 40 tradition à présent 46
la fête nationale du 14 juillet avaient
d'été marque exceptionnellement 45 par
un défilé militaire
bastille république voici les cônes
interarmées du sport de fontainebleau
qui a pour mission de former les
moniteurs d'éducation physique des trois
armées de la gendarmerie d'entraîner et
de perfectionner des capots active et
des appelés du contingent bain ou des
passeports
installé au camp guynemer en forêt de
fontainebleau 400 athlètes 500 moniteur
[Musique]
le centre d'instruction naval de
saint-mandrier et l'école des mousses le
simple de saint mandrier près de toulon
a ouvert ses portes en 71 1900 élèves de
la visio meubles aux 70 cours différents
ont peut-être missillier l'expression
larmes
électronicien les bacs de l'asm
transmetteur radio sans vieillissement
[Musique]
m
hemus qui sont basses un ouvrier sont de
futurs cadres de la marine
en 45 j'y reviens général de gaulle
président et le défilé sur la tribune
installée en face de la colonne petit
peu différemment ici entouré des membres
du gouvernement et hummer ou londres
univers de prague
voici l'école de formation initiale du
personnel navigant d'aulne hat chargée
de la formation initiale militaire et
technique et de la sélection en fonction
des aptitudes au pilotage d'avions
militaires les instructions aval
étant donné sur cap 10
et légale de formation initiale du
personnel navigant de nîmes-courbessac
créé il ya quatre ans
[Musique]
et qui assure la formation
professionnelle complète dans diverses
branches de spécialités psychotechniques
et fusiliers de l'est
[Musique]
appellerait aussi que l'once d'or 68
voulant donner un caractère populaire
cérémonies du 50e anniversaire de
l'armistice du 11 novembre 18 général de
gaulle avait décidé que le traditionnel
défilé des troupes auraient lieu du
cours de vincennes à la place de la
république en passant par le faut comme
ça mais la bastille et voici sur vos
écrans l'école technique de l'armée de
l'air d'orange sport
uniformes et recycle sur les plans
militaire morale et professionnelle
tous les personnels appartenant aux
corps du personnel navigant spécialistes
voici les jaguars qui passe dans le ciel
et jaguar qui est des informations au
canard
le jaguar est une réalité sur franco
britannique
construit par breguet et british
aircraft kobrich avec un armement qui
est composée principalement de jeunes
anti radar de missile air-mer
d'armements conventionnels et de poules
de reconnaissance
après quoi nous revenons sur terre
retrouvez-les écoles publiques de
l'armée de l'air de rochefort
[Musique]
et l'école d'enseignement technique de
l'armée de l'air de saintes
[Musique]
s'en suit toujours rochefort dans l'aîné
fil la voix la mission recruter des
techniciens de l'armée de l'air est
donné aux élèves une formation générale
aux techniques militaires physique et
morale vous voyez le moral le mot
technique revient très sport il prépare
donc c'est un jalon le sous-officier
bref des mécaniciens pour août et les
mécaniciens
[Musique]
ils sont sans armes pourquoi vous posez
vous la question est bien à quoi
réponse est simple parce qu'ils ont
entre 16 et 18 ans
[Musique]
on
et vous
[Musique]
le drapeau de la garde républicaine de
paris qui porte je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure au moment où passait les
cavaliers les noms des batailles
d'hamsik devienne la nouvelle que les
1,2 pouce et l'index
[Musique]
deux compagnies maintenant de la garde
républicaine je vous ai appelé tout à
l'heure au début
qu'ils descendent du gué royal organisé
par saint louis et que les gardes
républicains de paris sont issus des
écoles préparatoires de gendarmerie ils
sont spécialement chargé des services de
surveillance de la capitale
assistant de manifestations de nerfs et
son île pour le dire
le régime en faveur des parisiens
[Musique]
le drapeau de la gendarmerie mobile me
semble-t-il c'est exact c'est le drapeau
de la gendarmerie mobile et deux
escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
la gendarmerie mobile fait partie des
réserves générales placé en tournant à
la disposition des nouveaux publics
elle a été créée en juillet 1921
c'est à dire qu'elle a à peine dépassé
le demi siècle
voilà qui explique son art martial les
escadrons sont répartis sur tout le
territoire
[Musique]
le président toujours debout
plus de chaleur plus d'allégresse
plus de simplicité
[Musique]
sortant de l'écran mais nous allons la
rattrape et bien sûr la compagnie de
gendarmes auxiliaires du contingent
depuis avril 71 la gendarmerie nationale
accueille des appelés du contingent qui
sont volontaires pour servir lancé
[Musique]
maintenant ce matin m l'armée de faire
autrement dit vous voyez que nos caméras
sont disposés en deux endroits devant la
tribune et un petit peu avant maintenant
que les gendarmes sont passés nous
voyons le premier groupe de chasseurs
mécanisée gemain dédain en 1917 en 40
la belgique dunkerque en 45 libération
de colmar puis saint nazaire en 62
l'algérie actuellement stationnés à
reims 10e brigade mécanisée de mécaniser
des forces de manière il est doté de
matériel à mx 13 mais on ne voit pas de
véhicules cette année
et en fait ce sont les véhicules du
service de quart no qu'elle est arrivée
tout à leur insu j'espère dès ce matin
il n'y en a pas
[Musique]
toujours le premier groupe de chasseurs
mécanisée le fanion du premier qui
symbolise le drapeau des chasseurs et
que vous voulez voir porte la fourragère
aux couleurs de la médaille militaire la
croix puis à 14,8 et les médailles
commémoratives de 1166 empire
[Musique]
toujours le premier groupe de chasseurs
mécanisée qu'il est
[Musique]
le 13e bataillon de chasseurs alpins
qui s'est distingué mur la deuxième
guerre mondiale en anglais et dans la
somme principalement
[Musique]
c'est le 13e bca qui vient de se voir
confier la garde de l'unique drapeaux de
toutes les unités de chasseurs relançant
l'usiné dé placer un seul drapeau
quant au bataillon et conduit 150 hommes
et 120 v se drapant dans je parlais le
voici
ce bataillon du matériel technique qui
lui permet de se déplacer stationner et
vivre en haute montagne toute saison
quelles que soient les conditions
atmosphériques et les personnels sont
issus pourtant de toutes les régions de
france encore biais d'une majorité de 75
% pour la région rhône alpes dans le sac
va tout va
[Musique]
il
m
d'ailleurs je vous annonce messieurs le
boulevard beaumarchais monde un tout
petit peu
[Musique]
toujours 2 13e bataillon de chasseurs
alpins tenue blanche et les skis
le blanc pour se camoufler en cas de
besoin long sur blanc que vous soyez
devant un post war et blanc de la poste
de couleur blanc sur blanc vous voyez ce
que cela donne sur la neige on ne les
voit pas et pourtant ils sont là est un
peu là
[Musique]
le 5e régiment d'infanterie héritiers
l'héritier d'un mot peu en prenant
souvent dans l'armée héritier des bandes
de guyenne devenu en 15 1 69 le régime
15 189
peu importe à peu près ce moment-là
régime à l'égard du roi de navarre et
qui est l'un des plus anciens ne part
mais le roi de babar le roi de france et
de navarre
henri iv et l'on remonte on arrive par
le boulevard henry cap
il a participé à toutes les campagnes ce
régiment sous la royauté pendant la
révolution sous l'empiré la restauration
en 39 ya 40 ans bientôt et des temps de
rennes il combat dans les vosges quand
44 devant la rochelle et royan
les poulains
sont aux couleurs des armes en afrique
jaune pour les troupes de la marine le
bleu marine et pour l'art blindés la
cavalerie bleu clair
jaune donc infanterie
[Musique]
que je me permets de répéter les
molaires des poulains pour ceux de nos
téléspectateurs qui sans avoir un poste
de en noir et blanc
[Musique]
les artilleurs auront leur foulard
[ __ ] il est temps
je suis anti
toujours les foulards jaunes toujours
l'infamie pour les artilleurs joly dit
nous verrons l'an vouloir plus tard
le 23e régiment d'infanterie de marine
la marne
la première hier le chemin des dames en
40 et l'a combattu jusqu'au bout en
argonne
il a contre attaqué sur la célèbre top
300 cadres préfèrent main le drapeau que
vous voyez sera sauvée et rejoindra de
régime en 1945 après 45 indochine
l'expédition de suez la mauritanie
l'algérie depuis une dizaine d'années le
23e ligue marc et aux cornes maisons
laffitte affectés à la défense
opérationnelle des territoires au sein
de la deuxième division militaire et
j'aime beaucoup ce pays' fiers et forts
grogne est mort quand vous rapprochera
messieurs dames un peu en colère vous
répéterez la devise de ce 23e régiment
d'infanterie de marine
je vous le répète fier des ports grogne
est mort
et la musique qui joue la musique
principale des troupes de marine est
rattaché un ce 23e et riaient main
[Musique]
il
le régiment de marche du tchad suit le
23e régiment d'infanterie paris et
tandis que ceux ci
terminent leur passage
moi
je voudrais dire un mot tout de même du
régiment de marche du tchad
lorsqu'en 40 le tchad répondu à l'appel
du 18 juin 40 de londres le régiment des
tirailleurs sénégalais du diable serait
unanime dans sa volonté de continuer le
combat
le commandement en sera confiée un
lieutenant-colonel de cavalerie arrivant
par londres le caire le futur maréchal
leclerc de hauteclocque qui lance son
régiment
contre les italiens de sésame et c'est
notre amour souqués coup franc les
tchadiens avec les diots massue et
d'autres jurent de ne s'arrêter
c'est la célèbre phrase je la répète
telle qu'elle a été prononcée que le
jour où le drapeau français flotte ratio
metz et strasbourg
[Musique]
le régime en fer de lance de la cabane
de flair et sa jonction avec montgomery
à tripoli vizille participent à la
campagne de tunisie
un officier de ce régiment après la
libération balançant basse et julien
avis il ne se résume le capitaine tonnes
arrive le premier à l'hôtel de ville le
24 août 1944
[Musique]
ce régiment de marche du tchad pénètre
avec les chars maintenant strasbourg il
est maintenant en gare misant à
montlhéry dans la banlieue sud de paris
nous
je n'aime pas prononcé de grands mots de
montceau nord de mon flanc images se
suffisent à elles mêmes
mais si le l'adjectif le vieux peut
s'appliquer à une unité
c'est bien ça
parce qu'en caroline fallait y croire
dit se battre à ce moment là en afrique
tenir un serment de koufra faire flotter
les couleurs françaises sur mais ces
surfaces bourg et bien c'est un rallye
difficile et qui a tout de même été
tenue dans des conditions que l'histoire
a retenu que vous savez
[Musique]
à
et
le 1er régiment d'artillerie de marine
qui veut créée par richelieu en 1622
merci monsieur le cardinal le 1er
régiment d'artillerie de marine est
actuellement gamme is en hamelin la
lecture d'un cinéma 77 et matériels
c'est à dire un canon de 155 quant aux
mouvements sont servis par des engagés
des appelés par marc de région
parisienne orléanaise genèse poitevine
l'ancienne et des départements
d'outre-mer passant là devant les deux
marichal
[Musique]
oh
beaucoup de monde beaucoup beaucoup de
monde on veut de ces gens qui regardent
et des trois jeunes lorsque
pour la première fois le défilé ici à la
bastille je rappel c'est en 1945
aussitôt après la libération du
territoire le 9e régiment du saint
esprit le numéro 9 dans l'ordre de
bataille et unsa la récré de la
convention en 1993 à l'époque il était
vêtu d'un dolman écarlate qui lui valu
le nom du ca rouge et il combattra dans
tout les matins de la révolution et de
l'empiré aujourd'hui les bains garnison
a promis une fort jolie cité médiévale
située à 90 km au sud-est de familles
séparées chemin de reconnaissance du
premier comme d'hab
équipé b m
les sens mais laissons jeune je serai
présent corps ne défile pas
[Musique]
oh
le 120e régiment du train
il
qui veut créé en 1973 par simple
changement d'appellation du gie ne nous
en apprend pas mal des initiales bm
l'armé légale cité on planet année d'un
majeur une compagnie de commandement de
l'instruction
un groupe comme instruction des recrues
un groupement d'instruction technique le
1er avril 69 il s'installe à
fontainebleau dans les quartiers
dernière et de lariboisière ancien
quartier de l'école d'application
d'artillerie jusqu'à la guerre de 39 45
[Musique]
jadis les régiment du train étaient
souvent stationné dans l'est y avait
pour mission de transporter en toute
circonstance avec monde et du des
précisions des règlements toutes les
unités du corps de bataille sur leurs
positions de combat
il se caractérise et aussi avec des
physionomies libérables par exécutions
devraient quand même être une
instruction pousser les personnels et le
culte du matériel automobile la kate
comme un demi siècle
ils ont communiqué à toute la france
soit peu près
couleur blanc
[Musique]
le 58e régiment de thomas - de
transmission qui est essentiellement
charge d'assurer des liaisons
téléphoniques et télégraphiques entre
les postes comme enfant de la huitième
division et ceux du premier campagne en
garnison à compiègne ou jeanne d'arc
faite prisonnière et où naquit le
capitaine guynemer
le 58e et à planter autant de royallieu
séjour maire de juin 41 ou 44 avant
d'être redirigée vers l'est comme la
mort du nazisme
plus de 58 déportés
[Musique]
il dispose de près de 900 à mes débuts
300 véhicules équipés des moyens de
transmission des plus modernes
gabriel radio notamment
là
[Musique]
on
et bouna bleu clair après les arbres
toobin
[Musique]
le 5e régiment du génie qui veut
commander en 1889 par le colonel chaque
fois devenue depuis la récompense il est
implanté à versailles
en plus de sa mission d'instruction il
poursuit les tables de chemin de fer en
métropole sur le réseau militaire- bay 7
cf par exemple le démontage du pont de
sospel et la pause table foulard noir
régis main spécialisée chargée de
mission ministérielle le cinquième du
génie est aussi un régime au parisien et
à ce titre élite souvent sollicité par
exemple la construction de passerelles
de tribunes de tela somain du maniement
du mont valérien où pour le dégagement
assez récemment dans la colonne du
palais du louvre
il met en oeuvre des matériels divers
vacants et non comme acteur en gentil de
camouflage d'insomnie de manutention de
purification des eaux même vous voyez
c'est là où tu technique vison d'un mot
qu'il est à la fois sap et camino
le 1er régiment de chasseurs
parachutistes arrivant par le boulevard
henri iv et en 1943 à partir de la
compagnie nerfs numéro un
le premier chasseur parachutiste a pris
part à mende campagne italie quand même
de france indochine alsace durant
l'hiver 44 40
il a toujours été engagés dans les
opérations des bulles ici il est parti
en opérations extérieures en 61 après 16
ans d'absence il a rejoint la métropole
il est aujourd'hui basée à pau et
appartient à la 2e brigade parachutiste
dans le pc d'armes et l'art ces hommes
portent sur leurs épaules est le
charognard de l'armée de l'air le
foulard et jaune avant prix
vous voyez l'idée vient présider au
choix deux régiments qui défilent devant
le président de la république devant la
foule à paris et devant vous mais
mesdames et messieurs téléspectateurs et
téléspectatrices représenter le plus
grand nombre possible de ville de
garnison faire participer pleinement la
province à ce qui se passe à paris
pour
en province la nouveauté aujourd'hui est
essentiellement la suppression de tous
les engins motorisés avions grand défilé
militaire initiative est la conséquence
des mesures d'économie de carburant
décidée par les pouvoirs publics
le 8e régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine
vingt-quatre années d'existence 14 à
n'être qu'un pâle ils sont tous des
engagés volontaires venus de france
venus de l'hexagone veut dire les
départements d'outre-mer c'est d'un
régiment de grands notables sa vocation
et l'intervention extérieure et la
disponibilité des gens métier qui le
composent le rapport d'assemblée brooks
ce soit dans des délais très brefs et
arabes 8e promène d'un béret rouge ou la
casquette vert de leurs tenues combat ça
dépend sous des latitudes professionnels
et techniciens
ils sont en contact avec leurs
homologues des pays voisins
les hommes du détachement qui défilent
sous vos yeux arbore à côté du brevet
français
le brevet de parachutiste allemand
français intéressés soit par leur
réinsertion dans la vie civile à l'issue
de leur contrat soit mort promotions
militaires
il consacre une part de leur temps à
perfectionner leurs instructions
générales et acquérir une formation
professionnelle et là je suivrai le mot
du maréchal lyautey le militaire qui
n'est que militaire est un mauvais
militaire
7 h 20 de la préparation militaire
parachutiste de la 1re région militaire
[Musique]
j'ai dit de la préparation militaire
ce ne sont pas encore des militaires par
conséquent ils sont sans armes
l'instruction au sol et en vol est
dispensé soit sous forme de période
bloquées toujours 8 d'instruction au
sort des capots d'instruction en vol
soit sous forme d'instruction échelonné
pendant les week-ends après avoir
effectué quatre sauts le jeune homme
reçoit de brevets parachutistes
prémilitaire pas d'armes
ils ne sont pas militaires il porte une
tenue il faut la préparation militaire
ou larouche
[Musique]
la brigade de sapeurs pompiers de paris
créé par napoléon 1er en 1811 le corps
des sapeurs pompiers depuis sept ans et
richard reggab mission principale
d'assurer en toutes circonstances la
protection et la sécurité des personnes
et des biens contre l'incendié ribéry
nous exposant toutes natures sa
compétence territoriale je parle la
brigade de sapeurs pompiers de paris qui
défilent devant vous cette compétence
s'étend sur paris la seine-saint-denis
les hauts-de-seine val-de-marne
elle couvre donc une superficie de 760
kilomètres carrés soyons alerte soyons
chaleureux mais restons précis c'est à
dire une zone de 6 millions 500 mille
sinon 7 millions d'habitants
et pour l'année dernière son bilan
opérationnel se traduit par coup plus de
80 mille interventions non plus de 5000
asphyxie et plus de 12000 à st
je voudrais vous dire que 2 102
sapeurs-pompiers officiers
sous-officiers ont été blessés au cours
de ces interventions
en 1973 il vienne nous sauver
ils viennent vous aider ils nous sortent
du feu mais il en pâtissent de même ils
défilent cette année à pied sans leur
véhicule leurs véhicules sont en général
fort impressionnant je ne sais pas s'ils
sont leurs véhicules l'année prochaine
mais c'est la première fois que je les
vois défiler ainsi à pied
les fusiliers marins et commandos de la
marine
[Musique]
les six commandos qui donnèrent
naissance aussi compagnie du groupement
de fusiliers marins commandos ont repris
il ya deux ans leur appel nations
traditionnelles ne commando jaubert très
pen françois de penfentenyo de montfort
et hubert unités parachutistes à
vocation essentiellement maritime le
groupe uap co
comme l'on dit encore au point des
initiales de recevoir des missions
extrêmement variés les fusiliers marins
peuvent intervenir par air héliportage
au parachutage raid 100 féminin surface
haussmann et ils sont tous formés à
l'école des fusiliers de lorient leurs
aînés ont combattu nx fluide durant la
première guerre mondiale et cette année
outre qu'elle marque le 30e anniversaire
du débarquement du demande aux pieds
faire à ouistreham le 6 juin 44
nous en avons parlé longuement il y à un
mois et bien cette année 74 marque la
60e 60e anniversaire de la bataille de
dixmude en belgique à laquelle
participèrent les fusiliers marins
commandos
les hommes de clemenceau air 98 le porte
avions de combat léger le premier
porte-avions français conçu dans nos
apprenants depuis le porte-avions béart
qui avait été mis en service en 1928
mis sur cale en 55 clemenceau est en
plein service en 61
c'est un gars peuvent loger 40 millions
les hommes de l'escorteur d'escadre
labourdonnais admis au service actif en
58 et 7 et squatteurs fait partie d'une
série de bâtiments conçus pour la lutte
anti aériennes et impie sous-marine les
escorteurs de ce type sont aménagés pour
la détection et la conduite de missions
aériennes toujours ceux de l'escorteur à
vous donner
[Musique]
les hommes du sous marin nucléaire
lanceur d'engins le redoutable
une série qui comporte cinq unités le
terrible est le foudroyant sont
également opérationnels
l'indomptable le tenant le serons 77 et
79 les âmes un pub du sous-marin espadon
sous marins océaniques conçu pour la
navigation sous marine de longue durée
construit au havre est en plein service
en 1960
[Musique]
l'armée de l'air maintenant un groupe de
trois compagnies précédé du drapeau de
la 10ème escadre de chasse équipée de
mirage iii c est le super mister b 2 ici
ces trois compagnies sont des hommes de
la base aérienne 110 de creil de la
cendre à cambrai et de l'a 104 du
bourget qui assure à présent des
missions d'instruction de sélection et
l'accueil et c'est au bourget que les
meilleurs pilotes en leur premier
contact avec l'armée de l'air
[Musique]
vous
la base de creil porte le nom du colonel
salary man pour la france la base de
cambrai le nom de rené mouchotte
l'espérions au dessus de la belgique à
rome
[Musique]
et le brochet appelle le bush n'a pas
que je sache tout au moins de nom
spéciale évoquant fin des officiers
qu'il commandait deuxième groupe de
trois compagnies avec le drapeau la 64e
et scabreux transpose la base aérienne
d'evreux la base aérienne de
villacoublay la base aérienne de saint
cyr
[Musique]
ils ont de la base aérienne 107 de
villacoublay le son nom est étroitement
associée au début de l'histoire de
l'aviation dans le monde à présent vide
à combler le lieu de stationnement des
mystérieuses du clam et les morane
saulnier paris et nord 262 duguay
[Musique]
on marque le pas la raison en est toute
simple la vitesse à laquelle s'écoule
les corps d'autres au précédent a été
ralentie par un événement qu'est je
passais plus en plus loin à la jonction
du boulevard beaumarchais puis luc
albert et qu'on ne veut pas voir d'ici
[Musique]
le premier groupement domicile stratégie
premier gms
[Musique]
on
l'escadron des fusiliers commandos et
d'intervention de nîmes unitaire aux
portes et c'est des écoles de
spécialisation les possibilités
d'intervention et enfin les sections
cynophile les futurs chiens militaires
sont recrutés dans le secteur civil
ferme amateurs membres d'un groupe de
chiens de défense dressèrent et de leurs
professionnels ils sont achetés entre 14
et 18 mois à la suite d'une série de
peste et selon des critères
morphologiques technique physiologique
les chiens de race berger allemand en
entrevue plus de 90% dans ses effectifs
mais on y rencontre également des
bergers de bronze des bouvier des
flandres et bergers belges ou des
dobermans qui sont soumis aux
différentes épreuves d'agressivité de
défense d'accoutumance ou coup le feu
les trois armées comporte environ 2500
équipes cynophiles
[Musique]
le personnel féminin l'école interarmées
des personnels militaires féminins de
caen et l'an dernier avant quand salamé
terre besoin d'une école à dieppe qui a
fermé ses portes il ya une dizaine de
jours elle est implantée c'est l'école
au quartier koenig a vu kilomètres de
caen est là pour mission d'assurer la
formation de base des jeunes filles des
trois armées officiers ou sous-officier
[Musique]
non
rappelons qu'il y à trois dames ou
gouvernement actuel
le personnel féminin de l'armée de terre
oui
le personnel féminin de la marine
le personnel militaire féminin de
l'armée de l'air
elle défile tout et elle pense pas leur
avancement
par exemple dans l'armée de l'air le
personnel d'activ est composée
d'officiers et de sous-officiers
d'envahir arge et comporte des graves de
l'ariège chi militaire général jusqu'au
premier grade d'officier général inclus
vous voyez elles peuvent depuis le
général de brigade
celles ci sont de la marine
[Musique]
en faisant du personnel féminin de la
marine des officiers et officiers
mariniers nom et son déficit à part
entière on a voulu établir une égalité
de droit aussi étroite que possible
entre les hommes et les femmes
voici les officiers féminins de l'armée
de l'air le personnel navigant sur les
fonctions de convoyeuse de l'air à bord
des avions de transport militaire et de
nouvelles spécialités sont offertes à
leurs activités
c'est ainsi que l'armée de l'air
comptera bientôt parmi ses effectifs des
contrôleurs de la sécurité aérienne et
des contrôleurs de la circulation
aérienne militaire féminin et là les
chiens la légion est représentée
aujourd'hui vraiment pleinement jamais
je crois tout au moins jamais depuis une
quinzaine d'années elle n'aura été aussi
bien représentés d'abord les pionniers
les pionniers ouvre la marche
ils doivent ce privilège de précéder la
musique à une ordonnance de 1759 la
barbe le tablier de cuir lâche sur
l'épaule tout en rappelant comment
puis-je dire
le faste des armées impériales évoque le
bâtisseur que plus toujours le déjeuner
[Musique]
le pal démissionnaire et puis la musique
principale de la légion étrangère sans
exécutant divisé en batterie et harmonie
dix des vingt clairan dame a pris porte
deux voire trois instruments il joue
avec le même brio aussi bien du corps
que de la trompette de cavalerie
[Musique]
et
le goût de la célèbre marche des képis
blancs
le chapeau chinois cet instrument à
percussion que vous voyez arriver avec
deux nappes
c'est en somme c'est des queues de
cheval voici le chapeau chinois et ses
queues de cheval qui l'homme rappelle
d'une vieille coutume de l'islam on
exposait devoir attendre des chefs la
queue du cheval tu es sous lui
[Musique]
il
mais chez giscard d'estaing toujours
debout
c'est sa manière de saluer les troupes
qui défilent devant lui puisque un défi
à pied le 1er régiment étranger vous
voyez un régiment de la légion étrangère
ils recrutent il sélectionne il instruit
il faire des personnels dans l'ensemble
de la légion on a concédé pas moins d'un
groupement opérationnel immédiatement
disponibles et vous entendez toujours
instruire technique dû prononcer
plusieurs fois le nom de qualités
morales
n'insiste plus maintenant tellement
qu'avant autant qu'avant sur selon après
entre guillemets le passé de gloire et
crs et le langage unitaire le langage
documents militaires change il devient
plus humain plus concret plus quotidiens
plus chaleureux il s'adresse davantage
aux choeurs qu'à la mémoire de
l'histoire
nous
[Musique]
après le premier étranger le 1er
régiment étranger de cavalerie d'orange
le deuxième étranger d'infanterie
libérateur de l'italie le 2e régiment
étranger de parachutistes dans un
instant qui est le cas lui
et qui fut larguée sur le camp retranché
de dien bien phu
c'est ainsi que se termine ce défilé le
président de la république après avoir
assisté salue les personnalités
présentes et tous ont rien salon le
général ou étant salués selon protocole
par le général il présentait le défilé
le président de la république va rentrer
à l'elysée
vous savez que le 14 juillet ce n'est
pas seulement ce défilé militaire
le président souhaite également que les
fêtes donne lieu à des réjouissances
populaires président ici inconscient
anglaise chef du protocole toujours
présent dans les grandes cérémonies cinq
grands feux d'artifice seront tirés à
22h15 notamment devant le palais de
chaillot et de la butte montmartre
la ville de paris organise des grands
bals publics aux tuileries place dans
blogo et elle a décidé en outre de
subventionner toutes les initiatives
privées sur la place publique ou orange
donc non seulement de 16 casernes de
sapeurs pompiers mais également sur une
petite place devant les fontaines
publiques etc l'année jusqu'à 1h30 du
matin au défilé populaire nous avons vu
dans un instant une réception
décontracté à l'elysée fawaz m'emballe
public peu d'artifices illuminations
tout a été prévu pour que les fêtes de
ce 14 juillet se déroule dans une
atmosphère chaleureuse
le 14 juillet ce n'est pas seulement
paris c'est toute la france dans toutes
les grandes villes défilés concerts à
château chinon
monsieur mitterrand a convoqué tous ceux
de ses sympathisants qui prévenir une
grande fête populaire et c'est donc là
dessus que se termine comme nous avons
commencé notre émission
14 juillet du défilé du 14 juillet
tandis qu'à 52 mètres de hauteur la
balle génie de la bastille le génie de
la liberté dressé sur cette colonne de
juillet nous contemplent en ce jour de
fête nationale en ce jour de liberté la
liberté de pensée la liberté de dire la
liberté d'écrire la liberté d'affirmer
nos convictions politiques sociales
religieuses
celle que nous voulons des gens libres
dans un pays libre
c'était sur ce fond de ciel bleu et gris
de paris
un reportage de gérard herzog avec les
commentaires de léon zitrone
nous saluons les téléspectateurs de la
première chaîne et ceux de la deuxième
chaîne puisque nous étions ensemble
aujourd'hui et je m'en réjouis
ici la place de la bastille la fin du
défilé du 14 juillet à vous cognacq jay
[Musique]